I just mentioned that the rules of grammar enforce certain constraints on
written and spoken language.
Later in the lesson, we will get into a similar set of rules for
visualizations and charts called the Grammar of Graphics.
But for now, I simply want to show you a few of the most common chart types.
I mentioned that there are a finite amount of possible charts.
But even so finite can still be quite a large number as you can see here and
there are even more charts that are not included.
This is a flow chart created by Andrew Abela to
help navigate the somewhat overwhelming amount of different chart types.
Which in and of it's self, is quite effective.
You can find a larger PDF of this graph on extremepresentation.com.
Which is Andrew Abela's site.
And all the choices of possible chart types, I've seen very great.
You always have to consider how familiar an audience is with a given chart type
and how long a graphic takes to digest.
When I say digest here, I really mean understand and interpret.